raise your hand if you have hip and knee
pain
all right a couple of us are raising our
hands in here southwest medical's
optimum care
orthopedics and spine is there for you i
spoke with one of their doctors to learn
more take a look
we're talking about problems with hips
and knees and as a former athlete
i understand this yeah right
what is the significance behind behind
this and what are you seeing out there
uh it's a prevalent a lot of people with
hip and knee pain
at very stages of of severity
and it causes different amount of
disability and limitations in lifestyle
depending on what
people are trying to do in their lives
and what they're expecting
from their bodies so um even though it's
uh a lot of times generally the the same
cause
it's very different in how it affects
each individual person
for sure so when do you start actually
experiencing hip and knee pains
usually it's usually so people generally
start
experiencing hip and knee pain after an
injury or probably more commonly than
that
it's just a natural process of aging
and uh degenerative arthritis is
probably the most common cause of hip
and knee pain
i've had grandparents with those issues
so i completely understand so what are
the most common
um issues when you see these when you
see these problems out there
well um really it people come in to see
me when it starts to affect their
activities of of
life yeah you know if they like to
exercise if they like to walk if they
um want to get out and do things and be
active
and the pain starts to limit those
activities
then that's usually the time that people
start coming in to see
a physician like myself to try and get
resolution to the problem
so dr hansen what are some of the common
conditions that actually cause
hip pain sure so um
when we refer to hip pain we refer to
pain coming from the hip
joint now there's pain that comes from
inside the hip joint that's most
commonly arthritis
inflammation of the hip joint where the
ball and the socket come together
that arthritis cause that inflammation
arthritis means
inflammation of the joint can cause
destruction of the cartilage but outside
of the joint
we have muscles and tendons and nerves
so we can have uh hip abductor
tendonitis there's hip
abductor tears there's bursitis
the greater trochanteric bursa can cause
a lot of pain
around the hip joint what about when
they point to their knees
like yeah yeah what are what are those
most common conditions
there's the meniscus and that is a
common source of pain for young
athletes um you can get tears of the
meniscus the meniscus is a
fibrocartilage structure there's one on
the inside of the knee one on the
outside of the knee
and there you can get tears in it in
that that can cause painful popping
and catching sometimes locking and then
as
people age again the most common thing
would be arthritis when you list those
those treatment options people have for
these types
yeah so um first like i said
activity modification would probably be
the simplest right if we're overdoing it
we need to back off
um anti-inflammatory medications
listen to your body out there folks
often care orthopedics and spine you can
get more information if you call
ortho 702-724-8877 be right back